My name is Mitvatov.
I'm really sweaty.
And I really love Metal Gear.
So listen to me sing Metal Gear songs.
Woohoo!
Petals of white cover fields flowing in grieving tears.
And all the hearts once new, old and shattered now.
Love can kill.
Will die give me wings to fly?
Fleeing this world so cold, I just wonder why.
Dramatic zoom.
Cold as the dark.
Now my words are frosted with every breath.
Still the hate burns while growing inside this heart.
When the wind changes course, when the stars align, I will
reach out to you and leave this soul behind when heavens
divide.
I don't know what else to say.
I'm really nervous.
Metal Gear?
Metal Gear.
I don't know.
I really thank you guys.
I hope you guys have been enjoying the karaoke relay so far.
Everybody sounded great And I hope you there's still lots of
people left.
So have lots of fun today When heavens divide I will see the
choices within my hands How can we ever protect and fight
with our tiny soul?
Let me shine like the sun through the doubts and fear Do you
feel the storm approach as the end draws near?
When heavens divide, time will come to softly lay me down
Then I can see a face that I long to see And for you, only
you I would give anything Leaving a trace for love to find
no way When heavens divide
Yeah!
I'm gonna have to like speed route, speed, speed run through
these songs so much time to talk, but I'm a yapper.
Let's go.
I will dive into the fire, spilling the blood of my desire.
The very last time my name scorched into the sky.
When heaven's divide, I will see the choices within my
hands.
How can we ever protect and fight with our tiny souls?
Let me shine like the sun through the doubts and fear Do you
feel the storm approach as the end draws near?
When heavens divide, time will come to softly lay me down
then I would see a face that I long to see and for you only
you I would give anything leaving a trace for love to find a
way when heaven's divine
for love to find a way when heavens divide
yeah hold on I have to transition one second give me a
second give me a second oh my gosh wait all my stuff is all
over the place hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on hold
on oh my gosh go away Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on,
hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, okay, okay, okay.
I'm so nervous, oh my god, okay.
Blind in the deepest night, reaching out, grasping for
fleeting a memory all these thoughts keep piercing this
broken mind I fall but I'm still standing motionless far in
the distance there is light a light that burns these scars
of old all this pain reminds me of what I am I'll live I'll
become all I need to be
Whoa Whoa
Words that kill Would you speak them to me Your breath so
still, it makes me believe in the Father's sins.
Let me suffer now and never die.
I'm alive.
Except I'm not, I'm actually a ghost.
You know, it's so funny, you know, you're there.
I never die because I'm a ghost.
I mean, I'm already dead, but like, you know, it's like
undead, but not really undead because I'm not a zombie.
I'm not a ghost, but what does it, what do I really count as
in a, like, where do I fall under?
I'm having an existential crisis in the middle of this song.
Oh my gosh.
Anyway, okay.
Let's just keep going, right?
Pride feeds their blackened hearts, and the thirst must be
quenched to feel.
hypocrisy cleansing flames is the only way to repent
renounce what made you words that kill would you speak them
to me with your breath so still it makes me believe this
part is so hard Our sins never die Can't wash this blood off
our hands Let the world fear us all It's just means to an
end Our salvation lies Beyond the truth Let me suffer now
In my heart I just know that there's no way to light up the
dark in his eyes.
Whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa.
Yeah!
The next song I've never sung before on stream, so I'm very
nervous about it.
Oh, okay.
I'm nervous about all these, but anyway, I'm gonna try and
sync it to the best ability that I can.
Here we go.
Oh, where's my song?
There it is.
I love you.
But it will never happen.
This feeling is so sad.
It's so sad.
The beginning, I don't know.
My name is normal, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
But when I'm out there, I'm sure I'll find you.
I'll be able to find you.
I'll be honest with you, I'll be able to see you.
love love listen to my heart more than love
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, this is all
about you.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
This is the world that will change the world.
On the other class, we are now together.
God gave us a chance, you know.
Time is just going to go.
I'm sure this will be the same.
You'll be in love with each other.
I'll be the same.
You'll be right now.
You'll be right back.
You'll be right.
This moment will probably be somehow, will be, will be.
What will be your feelings?
Are you too sweet?
How much are you?
Okay, one more song, one more song left, and then I'll
transfer you over to the next person.
If you don't know anything about Metal Gear, I hope that you
still enjoyed the songs and everything.
It's a great series, I really promise you.
the good word of metal gear right anyway my last song may be
a song that maybe even if you don't know metal gear you
might know this one because it is um it is the metal gear
song perhaps um but yeah my final song and then i'll pass
you over thank you guys for listening and uh oh my gosh hold
on let me get it up let me get it ready
With darkness and silence through the night What a thrill
I'm searching and I'll melt into you What a fear in my heart
But you're so supreme
I give my life, not for honor, but for you.
Psych it out.
In my time, there'll be no one else.
It's the way I fly to you.
I'm still in a dream, snaking up And someday you go through
the rain And someday you feed on a tree frog This ordeal,
the trial to survive The day we see new light I give my life
Not for honor, but for you
In my time There'll be no one else Oh my gosh, my voice is
cracking
Crime is the way I fly to
I'm still in a dream, snake eater.
This is the outro.
I forgot.
I was like, yes, this is the outro.
I was like, wait.
Wait.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Have fun with the rest of the karaoke.
And I'll see you guys.
later bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye what if we just have this playing in the outro
instead
it's time to redirect oh it's gone okay never mind you know
what bye